المدينه الفاضله التي لطالما حلم بها
الفيلسوف الشهير افلاطون ربما ستتحقق على
يد الملياردير الامريكي الى النصف له
الماسك اشترى مساحات واسعه من الاراضي في
ولايه تكساس ليشيد مدينته الخاصه على طول
نهر كولورادو المدينه تمكن موظفي شركاته
تسلا سبيس
تمكنه من العيش والعمل بحسب صحيفه
عدد من السكان المحليين في السن لكن عبر
اخرون عن مخاوفهم من تغييرات جذريه وبيئيه
ستحدث في المكان الهادئ الذي يعتاد العيش
فيه
[موسيقى]
ونذهب الى ضيفنا من القاهره استاذ الفلسفه
بالجامعه الامريكيه بالقاهره الدكتور احمد
عبد المجيد يسعد هالصباح دكتور احمد اهلا
وسهلا بك في صباح العربيه وللتنويه هذه
المره الاولى التي نستضيف فيها استاذ
فلسفه في برنامج صباح العربيه يعني لحسن
حظنا ومن سعدنا نتشرف فيك
اهلا بحضرتك الشرف كله ليا
وكان يعتبر هذه المدينه اللي هي يحلم بها
ويجب ان يحكمها فلاسفه هل بهذه الحاله
يرى نفسه فيلسوفا
[موسيقى]
يعني ربما يكون هذا ما يتصوره يعني ولكن
انا الحقيقه عندي عندي شويه
تشككات على على الموضوع ده يعني افلاطون
كان تصوره هو الحقيقه كان تصور في منتهى
الذكاء والعمق ان
المدينه الفاضله او المجتمع الفاضل
بتعابيرنا احنا دلوقتي الفكر النقدي
والعقلاني وقدره الانسان ان هو يفكر بشكل
متصق من الناحيه المنطقيه والعقلانيه
وعشان كده في ناس قالوا على على نظريه
افلاطون في المدينه الفاضله او سموها كلمه
يعني ان هي النظام المبني على المعرفه من
او كلمه معرفه بالاغريقيه القديمه
المشكله بتهيا لي في تفكير التقني والراس
مالي الحديث هو ان هو دايما بيفكر
بشكلين الشكل الاول فكره الميزتو اند او
الوسيله التي اللي هتبرر غايات معينه
والحاجه التانيه ودي مشكله كبيره في الفكر
الطاقني بشكل عام زي ما احنا شفنا مثلا
فيرس بتاع
بتاع
فيسبوك المشروع الجديد بتاعهم اللي هو
نزع الانسان من الواقع الحياتي بتاعه
وقدرته عقلانيا على التفاعل مع ده ولكن
يعني نامل ان هو لو فعلا بيفكر انا قريت
شويه عن المشروع بتاعه
والتقارير ان هو لو فعلا هيبقى في نوع من
رفع الاعباء الماديه
وتسهيل
السبل المعرفيه وهو لاخره ان يكون بدايه
لتكوين لبنه
هل هذا يعكس شخصيه ايلون ماسك او سيؤثر
على شخصيه ايلون ما
سك ايه بالظبط اللي
هيعكس شخصيه اللي هي فكره المدينه الفاضله
بتاعته او البيرفكت سيتي في صنايبر في
تكساس
نعم اكيد نحكي عن المدينه انا الحقيقه
عندي
نعم يعني انا
يعني من متابعاتي للسياسات اهل الماسك انا
الحقيقه مش عارف اذا كنت اثق في ان هو
هيكون افضل من يؤسس هذه المدينه الفاضله
ولكن
انا شايف ان هو ممكن يكون عنده فكره فعلا
لفكره الفسيليتيشن بتاعه الحياه ولكن زي
ما انا قلت التخوف الاساسي عندي
في الوقت بتاعنا كله يعني من الناس اللي
اتكلموا كتير عن عن الموضوع ده عن فكره
السكن وعلاقه السكن
بالبرفاكشن او ان انت تخلي الحياه اب بشكل
افضل بافضل شكل ممكن
والحقيقه اتكلم عن الموضوع ده من الحرب
العالميه الثانيه كان على ناخذ على سبيل
المثال مارتن هايدرو كان ليه تاثير كبير
جدا على الفلسفه المعماريه وعلى اغلب
المعمريين الكبار
في القرن العشرين منهم حتى ناس عملوا
مشاريع مهمه في المناطق العربيه زي
كلوديوس البسترين عمل مشاريع في الامارات
على حسب ما انا اعرف وكده كل هؤلاء كانوا
بيفكروا ان المعمار والمدينه الفاضله يجب
ان يرتبط برؤيه معرفيه اكتر منها رؤيه
تقنيه عن وسائل الراحه او حتى زي ما انا
قريت عن المشروع بتاع ايلين ماسك تسهيل
نعم دكتور احمد في تاريخ علم الفلاسفه
والفلاسفه القدماء وفلاسفه العصر
والفيلسوف ماسك ان صح التعبير هل كان فعلا
لديهم طموح لخدمه البشريه وان يكون
المخلصين للبشريه ام لديهم مقارب اخرى
طموحات سياسيه ومثلا ماسك اليوم
طبعا انا مش عايز اخوض في السؤال حضرتك
مهم جدا وظريف جدا طبعا انا محدش يقدر
يتكاهن بنوايا الناس بس من اللي انا قراته
في التقارير الاخباريه سواء في الصحافه
العربيه او على الانديفاندنت او غيرها ان
هو مثلا بيقول ان هيكون في
اجور البيوت هتكون مخفضه جدا للموظفين
بحيث ان هو يساعدهم على التركيز والابداع
في العمل ولكن طبعا انا في تصوري ان في
الاخر بالذات نوينج يعني او بمعرفتي
بسياسات ماسك من خلال حياتي في الولايات
المتحده فتره طويله وكده فهو في الاخر
الربح اكثر منه التفكير حقيقه في انشاء
مدينه على اسس معرفيه
تخدم الناس
وزي ما قلت لحضرتك من شويه انا كمان عندي
تخوف شويه من
التفكير التقني بمعنى ان طبعا ما حدش
بيقول ان التكنولوجيا مش مهمه ولكن بقى في
حقيقه مع التفاقم اللي حصل في السوشيال
ميديا وكل ده
نزع للمعرفه البشريه من الواقع بتاع
الانسان
وده ابتدى يسبب مشاكل نفسيه كبيره جدا
بنشوفها عند الطلبه في امريكا وكل انحاء
العالم
وبالتالي فكره السكن والعمل
ابتدت تفقد معناها لوجودي الاساسي فاتمنى
ان يكون اللي هو بيعمله ده فعلا
هدفه حاجه زي كده ويمكن يكون مخرج من
الازمات اللي ممكن تعملها الحياه في
الفضاء الافتراضي
المنافس له مارك زاكربيرج بيحاول يعملها
دلوقتي في
البيوت اللي عايزين يبيعوها على
الماتافيرس والكلام ده كله ههه يعني في كل
الاحوال ز من عجائب هي مدن عجائب صارت مش
مدن فضله شكرا جزيلا لك استاذ ده غير طبعا
التخوفات البيئيه اللي حضرتك اشرت اليها
يعني في كثير من السكان في المنطقه دي
عندهم تخوف من التصاريح اللي بيطلبها
للماسك وشركه ذا بورينج كومباني فيما
يتعلق بالنواحي البيئيه بالذات الحديث
شكرا جزيلا لك استاذ الفلسفه بالجامعه
الامريكيه بالقاهره الدكتور احمد عبد
المجيد